um what Ryan what do you think of the
fights there all right just all right
now they're great what do you think dude
let's get your thoughts guys do the hour
and a half long podcast on it uh I mean
it your thought I think that I love the
main ones program I love Jorge Masvidal
I think I think that in the UFC when you
have guys like Jorge Masvidal who live
eat and breathe fighting they're just
there's such fighters that there's no
room for anything other than that you're
gonna be competing against like he just
he just lifts the level up I would
imagine as a fighter and you go well I
don't have if I don't have that fire I
got to get the [ __ ] out of here I'm
gonna be come on you're confusing people
because you're saying this because we
were talking about Luke Rockhold outside
of us so you jumping right into that be
because Ben Askren eat sleeps and
breathes fighting [ __ ] you just got
knocked out yeah that's absolute kill it
always so there doesn't make sense what
you said no I'm not yawning Luke I'm
just talking about I was just talking
about Jorge Maz video on how he's Nick
Diaz 2.0 to me as far as just a
straight-up fighter and yeah I mean just
unbelievable
I mean it's so personal to him but he's
so he's so [ __ ] good that's not got
ever I think yeah crazy I don't like
seeing that I don't like seeing it I
hate seeing that I thought they'd have
taken out on a stretcher
they almost should have I just hate
seeing it and what I what I think is
interesting is that the UFC is such a an
unforgiving you know I wonder I wonder I
wonder now Ben Askren such an amazing
wrestler and he never lost wrestling in
nineteen know used his wrestling I want
to see and I think the same thing was
about to happen with Robbie Lawler and I
think if they fight again I would I
would put my money on Robbie law
interesting yeah so I'm so against Ben
Askren as great as he is and he's great
and a hell of an athlete I I do think
that he's primarily a wrestler and I do
think that that's a liability against
the higher echelon guys in the UFC like
Jorge mas yeah it's like not easy but I
think of him in the Pliny's kind of you
know Bob ciub I think if him and Jorge
fought a hundred times you get a
different result every time that's fair
that III that's fair I think Ben can
beat anybody in the world because you
couldn't get caught with us is why
crazy yeah I beat everybody yeah I know
what he does with world champs in the
training room destroyed yeah yeah I love
us again Anthony Pettis is like I'd
never embarrassed myself like that
trying to challenge you guys what's
hilarious to me is just how just there's
nothing like fighting me because before
this Ben Askren Grilli was the most
famous guy in this card if you look at
the polls everyone's you know saying
they would rather watch Ben Askren than
John Jones Amanda Nunez Jorge mods with
all
everyone Luke Rockhold he's very Michael
uh no he's more of a psyche trolls right
so people love to hate him so there's
that and then he was that you know he
wins this he gets a title shot and then
now it's like should he retire is it
over he's lost one fight for a while
flying me and basically to second yes I
do
let's you want him to take a year off
for his head I mean yeah I know it isn't
but I think he should six months um
Amanda knew Nia is the best ever by far
nice to have destroyed Holly [ __ ]
crazy how good she is
what do you think of John Jones Tiago I
think I think John Jones they people are
well Thiago's knee gave out sup a
hundred percent sure John Jones won
anyway and John Jones wins and John
Jones is the best and I thought I
thought I thought this is the first
fight literally I I mean the Gustin one
get sense so good I really that was a
gun that make sense guessing is that
good this is the first time I know
John's definitely beatable if he gets it
comes across the right guy he's
definitely beatable getting hit so
that's where I didn't see him get hit so
I didn't see him get so the way that
guy's dream was his chin was tested the
way that guide Thiago Santos hits is is
you can he just sits down and starts
throwing he's really really powerful and
I see why he's knocked so many people
out I did John Jones he got his he he
did he nice cage side I didn't see I've
guys who were caged I'm like oh no they
was it shows you how great of a chin
John has cuz he's getting blast but I
please backing up get hit
yeah my rating blows right
yeah I really didn't but there was
always something in the way there was
always a little bit of glove there's
always a little bit about that I was one
of the first time to John's defense
looked a little suspect it was the first
time I oh he's beatable if you went to I
I can kind of see why John's hesitant to
go to heavy weight ah really because
because guys can sit there that's like
well over if it's Frances thing Donna oh
yeah I'm ones over yeah yeah yeah use
that Batson up that he's doing cuz he's
so much bigger than one right what level
playing field me it's the heavyweight mm
the first moment oh that's what yeah
that makes sense right I think it's a
because he knows like that he might get
hit there and it's game over a
heavyweight and B he needs Dana White to
back up the bring trucks to use Krista
Lea's reference he needs to bring bring
trucks backed up to took out of a
heavyweight big time yeah well because
he's probably he's also removing he
those who thirty like when he walks
around dirt he's more than that uh you
can be but he's like to 27 to 30 these
guys ready five or shredded yeah but
these guys are doing Ghana's 260 cut
into two six five okay so that's a much
bigger man but if it goes past the first
round and got it France to be in trouble
John can grind and take you that
remember you can take France down like
that take a man John ado well it heavy I
still think you'd be heavyweight champ
but there's a reason why he's not
jumping at the opportunity he'd have his
hands full with [ __ ] steep Amy oh
such right yeah I mean if he if he had
hit like that and it could be a problem
there's also you know also him fighting
DC at heavyweight different animal to
yeah DC hits a little harder DC was
winning those early rounds to get ahead
kicked you know mm-hmm but that's the
first time went okay but he he's
actually beatable when I didn't think he
was even beatable
you didn't think he was I think anyone
beat John ever after now it Johnny I'm
carried out of the cage you know that he
had to be carried out what was it it was
it like he likes the one thing is that
he's got those tiny skinny legs and I've
always wondered and I was an ask you
this actually I've always wondered why
you wouldn't just hack at that front leg
over and over again cuz you get blasted
in the face or what did you blast in the
face
plus the out goes a smaller fighter but
and then also for like exciting
encountered you have to throw something
ahead of it right - one - she was doing
one thing kick until you get your time
and then get knocked out or taken down -
right what the Aguas have a success
story blonde its knee he was having
successfully but it's a split decision I
have a problem split decision I don't
know what's next for John let me look at
the light heavyweight rankings chin I
don't want even though yon knocked out
Luke I really don't see that Santa's
destroyed yon yes see what happens a DC
steep a Dominic gray is pretty next best
bet
how tall is Reyes athletic kid played
football good footwork he's been
fighting how long not that long
yeah my money is oh yeah John's gonna be
a heavy favorite in every fight yeah
besides DC yet heavy he just finds a way
to win man he just wins you know people
cuz seem to get a little bit closer but
they don't I was surprised didn't take
six for Jesus big kid really athletic
I'm surprised didn't take Santos down
that was a weird fight the word fight
it's entertainment then your boy Luke
yeah thought my god last week yeah I was
with him last week and I just first of
all I hope his jaw gets better
and you broke it fractures all right
yeah I hate season I I don't want to
speak for him and I don't want I don't
want to say anything you know I my
feeling is that he seemed a bit you put
on me what I tell you when you texted me
about the fight yeah what I tell you you
have ever gone always be so yeah I'm not
you know he was he kind of wants out
maybe he's not assigning that he'd like
he's scared and nothing now yeah then
when remember Luke is a hall-of-famer
he's had a great career two-time world
champion one night when you and I are
text I went if I had to bet I'd say he
doesn't want it as bad as these other
guys his other well their job has a lot
of other options Luke has a great career
after this
I really wants to paint this this isn't
a sad story this is a successful story
leaks out of phenomenal career two-time
world champion super famous in the UFC
dimepiece yeah Ralph Lauren model he has
other options and by the way is it sad
yeah but also every name any fighter
that you like evening fighter that you
like who sticks around long enough ends
up face down any fighter and part anyone
and it part of it also you can say well
sometimes people grow out of this
sometimes there's that there is that I
think that what happened with you and
and I think with Luke and sometimes
you've been doing this so long you grow
out of it how long is Luke if we go down
to his first fight he start fighting
2007 I mean that's a long [ __ ] time
12 years 12 years 12 years of this grime
I mean any idea how long the no I don't
lighting actually no I don't but I'll
tell you something that kind of training
all the time where you're like I think
I've outgrown this I think I want to do
something else if you always stand fire
for him ask me dog then maybe it's time
that his legs messed up here's the
issues with this his foot you know it's
it's it's a constant you're gonna grind
again Luke saw cher fire hall-of-famer
phenom Achra two-time world champion
fought the best beat the best lost some
of the best great fighter this is not a
sad story for someone to go well you
might not be into it because he has a
Ralph Lauren modeling contract is a
successful stories as successful says
you know what you know who else we're
talking about retired is Daniel Sanchez
what's he gonna do well he doesn't look
like Luke Rockhold no there's no
modeling contract hold on oh hey Ralph
Lauren ain't hiring Diego Sanchez hey
Maya
yes either all those shirts [ __ ]
ironed Diego Santa you know that I love
I love Diego Sanchez you know I love him
and you know the other does some he
fought I'm gonna have to take a moment
just to just to acknowledge him and
everything else he's awesome he's the
best he's awesome he's the best not a
model I'm not a model I was hoping that
his new cornerman guru was going to be
helpful here that guy is the best
he's gonna hand the mighty broadcast I
think I'm think about hiring him what's
up well he seems he had his hood on do
you have any thoughts on that guy
well I want you look at one video you
think watch out
let me see the knife saying you this
video Brian before the fight I went you
want a piece of deer Sanchez coach dude
he seems to be what's up bro
this the same grab-ass you do at the gym
of the stranger he seems to be totally
look at this dude look at the movements
of a shitty movement
listen listen I'll of the sass very
elusive right now look at this dude he's
what's up bro so well what's up bro no
look what's up now here comes a Nobel so
your ass what what the [ __ ] sake I keep
coming and he just keeps not being there
yeah look good lucky I hate fighting
guys like this because they're literally
invisible dude good luck and then once
he starts throwing elbows
once you get your distance this is
literally invisible technique I don't
even know what the by every time week
every time the back yeah
[ __ ] dude I didn't even see that elbow
dude dude here comes in ok come on [ __ ]
dude dude this guy he set that damn do a
nice video that was five unanswered
elbow I do that video it infuriate you
host that's one sent it to unanswered
said Brian I think I found your couch
that that's some voodoo [ __ ] and I'm
impressed movement coaches were the
craze for a second that is some
impressive [ __ ] I'd say what if there's
a leak ornaments do Sanchez it also
deals and lose that fight whether he had
this guy in this corner [ __ ] yeah
Michael Jesus he's one of those dudes it
just keeps getting better and better
Michael Chisolm he's ready that
welterweight man real right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]